once let's go ahead and get started
thank you everyone for coming we have a
visitor today who actually will
hopefully see more over time dr. Sonny
Lin is a new assistant professor in the
OHS you PSU School of Public Health in
in the Department of Health Management
and policy and she joined PSU and OHSU
since the School of Public Health is
part of both a few months ago and so
she's establishing her research and her
teaching of courses and so forth and in
fact we'll be teaching a course in
health informatics that Ted ladarius and
I originally developed at PSU and she'll
be taking over that she is going to talk
to us today about hospital health
information exchange and alternative
payment models which those of you kind
of in the clinical know know that
there's that's a lot of what's happening
now in terms of payment and hie and so
forth she has a bachelor's degree from
Northwestern University of master's from
Carnegie Mellon and finished her PhD at
University of Michigan this past spring
and her research mentor as someone who
probably many of you know or who have
heard of dr. julia adler Milstein who
actually left the university of michigan
and now is down at UCSF so I will turn
it over to sunny I thank you so much for
having me this works and I can come out
from behind the desk behind here I'm
really happy to be here and meet you all
I've heard a lot about the great stuff
that is happening here and thank you and
yeah so this is just a little bit of
the work that I did at Michigan so this
is a paper that was published in
American Journal of managed care a
couple of months ago so it's it's
actually been a while since I looked at
the data so this will be fun for me too
and I'm I'm I'm more than excited
actually to get your feedback response
and kind of your perspective on things
so so I kind of come at like come at
this from the policy angle and a lot of
times that can be really hard
from this perspective to really
understand what's going on at the
clinician or the organization level or
what's going on behind the scenes in any
one given organization which is why I'm
so excited to be here in this position
so I'm gonna give just like a brief
overview of the kind of policy side of
things and if I hope this is helpful and
kind of gives some context to the work
I'm doing so in the US care
fragmentation is estimated to be
responsible for about like 25 to 45
billion dollars of wasteful spending
each year and that includes spending on
things like redundant tests or avoidable
hospital admissions and so policymakers
are using payment models to try to
improve care coordination in the hope
that some of this excess funding excess
spending will kind of go away as many of
you probably know there's both federal
and state policies that are trying to
tie more more payments to what's called
alternative payment models or
value-based purchasing models I think
the most popular one here is the
Oregon's TCO 2.0 and CCO is those are
both examples of these kind of payment
models and technology is expected to
play a large role under these programs
so here's some of the use cases
population health analytics provider
identification and communication and
health information exchange for a
variety of different uses so the
research question that I went to it
wanted to address in this paper was
whether alternative payment models
promote greater engagement in hospital
health information exchange and I talked
about greater engagement it's very broad
term and I'll go into that a little
but whenever I talk about greater
engagement I just want you to think of
the goal of getting the right
information to the right person at the
right time so here's a kind of quick
primer in a federal alternative payment
model design which is what this paper
focus is on and I'm still learning more
about what's happening here in Oregon so
um
many of you know in the u.s. most
providers are paid on a fee-for-service
basis so here's an example with my
grandmother
so say she falls and breaks her hip and
she sees a provider who gives her who
she or her sure they say they gives them
a lump sum of money for the for whatever
services were rendered and she said to
the hospital for treatment and that
hospital gets some money and then she
sent to a skilled nursing facility for
rehabilitation afterwards and that
skilled nursing facility would then get
some money so under fee-for-service the
hospital has no incentive to coordinate
care between the hospital and these
skilled nursing facilities a lot of them
do which is great but sometimes if for
example the post the receiving post
acute care providers not in the same
organization or under the same like
umbrella or health system information
can get lost and oftentimes what that
leads to is a readmission so under a
fee-for-service payment model that
hospital actually gets more money as a
result of providing core quality care
coordination so this is a big problem in
a larger scale about one in five elderly
patients are readmitted to the hospital
within 30 days and this cost Medicare
about seventeen billion dollars in
potentially avoidable costs and so what
alternative payment models do is they
create an incentive for organizations
who work together to ensue to improve
care coordination so it's just got to
get a sense of how babies alternative
payment models are becoming in 2017 and
that's the native thirty four percent of
all health care payments we're linked to
some sort of alternative payment model
whether that be Medicare Medicaid or
private commercial alternative payment
models so I'll go into three of the main
kind of federal APM's right now and we
can have a policy discussion about why I
chose things if you're interested
these are the big ones that Medicare is
currently kind of pushing so under a cos
a cos are collectively rewarded or a cos
are a group of organizations that are
collectively rewarded if care for their
population comes in under a certain pre
specified amount so Aaron is a shion's
that share a lot of the same patients
can create an ACO and each year that
that patient body the spending on that
that those shared patients are summed oh
that's great sorry
each years spending on those patients
ourselves maybe this doesn't work that's
okay I compared to a benchmark and that
benchmark is set based on a historical
spending in order to try to keep
healthcare costs healthcare cost
increases from from increasing over time
so to date about ten percent of the US
population is covered in or some kind of
a CEO so under bubbled payments this is
a hospital centric payment model the
hospitals are paid per episode
regardless of the quantity or type of
services received and under Medicare's
bundled payment for care Improvement
Program or B PCI this bundled payment
includes
post acute care even if that care has
received outside of the hospital and
then patient-centered medical homes are
[Music]
primarily primary care practices that
are focused on providing comprehensive
patient centered coordinate coordinated
care and if included this in the study
because a lot of hospitals that exist in
healthcare systems that have a primary
care patient centered medical home like
OHSU and so under under patient centered
patient centered medical homes payment
models are often similar to either the
ACO or the bundled payment model okay so
what role does health information
technology have in alternative payment
models so here are some use cases
clinical decision support and
facilitating the use of evidence-based
practices predictive analytics patient
risk stratification and population
health management
I'm sure you guys can give me all sorts
of more interesting things to put on
here and it'd be interested in hearing
your thoughts on that
but for this paper what I focus on is
health information exchange for the
purposes of coordinating care after a
hospitalization so under the status quo
or paper-based information exchange less
than 50% of primary care providers
report receiving discharge information
for the recently hospitalized patients
and for the discharge information that
is sent up to 65% are missing important
components like lab results or follow-up
procedures test results and up to 88
percent don't actually arrive in time
for the patient's first follow-up visit
after a hospitalization so this is a
really big problem and as many here in
the room would probably believe
electronic health information exchange
promises to improve the completeness the
timeliness and the accuracy of the
information that's being exchanged with
in theory should lead to less redundant
and better quality post acute care I
don't know how many of you have seen
this paper come out but I thought it was
fun and dr. Atul Gawande is a really
great writer and what he talks about in
this paper is why doctors hate their
computers so even though we have all
this technology getting physicians to
use it and getting the right technology
to physicians at the right time is
actually quite hard given all the other
responsibilities efficient physicians
have to do so where I kind of see
fleshing out my research is looking at
hig adoption at use at different levels
of care so at the physician level it's
it's how do we make technology
accessible and easy to use for
physicians and providers and staff at
the organisation levels how do we help
organizations to use technology and
leverage it to improve patient care
and then at the system level which is
where this paper fits in is how do we
use technology to facilitate information
traveling across organizations in order
to support patient care so my prior work
in this area suggests that under a
fee-for-service payment model financial
incentives are a really large barrier to
health information exchange so for
example for-profit hospitals actually
share information for fewer of their
patients highly competitive pettite of
hospital markets are less likely to have
what's called a regional health
information exchange which is a
third-party organization that helps to
facilitate information exchange between
organizations and then competing
providers often choose to participate in
different health information exchange
approaches which limits the value that's
exchanged in any one given approach and
then often when you talk about health
information exchange improving care a
big question that comes up is well what
is the payers role because in theory the
payers are the ones that are going to
really benefit from this and in this
study we talked to a bunch of pairs and
we found that pair is really believe in
the value of information exchange but
they're cautious to invest in those
information exchanges for fear of
benefiting their competitors
however alternative payment models this
is my theory are situated to really
improve the state of information
exchange in the United States and that's
because these inter organizational
barriers that may be attenuated by the
financial models that's in these
alternative payment models so as I
mentioned before Medicare is has this
big goal of improving or of tying more
payments to these kind of alternative
payment models and value-based payment
models
and really are kind of ramping up
participation in these payment models so
again my research question here was the
alternative payment models promote
greater engagement in health information
exchange specifically for the purposes
of post acute care coordination so
there's been a lot of talk about the
importance of health information
exchange and alternative payment models
but a lot of the talk kind of focuses on
other use cases such as reporting or a
population kind of analytics and looking
at what kind of a community level like
disease registries and those kind of
things which are important but the
extent of HIA use for the purposes of
post acute care coordination has not
really been looked at and due to a lot
of the things I mentioned earlier there
are still reason to believe that even
under alternative payment models
information exchange might be limited so
for this paper I looked at four
different dimensions of health
information exchange at the national
level so the first was the volume or the
percent of patient transitions for which
information was exchanged electronically
the second was diversity or the variety
of data types that a hospital says that
they can routinely send to a receiving
provider the third was the breadth of
the variety of partner types that a
hospital says that they can send
information to and then the fourth was
the depth or the ways of accessing data
so I'll go into what each of these in
more detail later and then for the
independent variable looked at whether a
hospital participated in an alternative
payment model again those were the a cos
the B PCI program or the
patient-centered medical home program so
for volume or the percent of patient
transitions I looked at the percent of
patients that transitioned it to a
another care setting following
hospitalization and for whom information
was sent via electronic summary of care
record electronically so this came from
the Medicare EHR Incentive program
otherwise known as meaningful use and
this was for hospitals that attested to
stage two
program so the minimum requirement in
order to attest successfully for this
program was 10% and as far as I know
that hasn't changed and the new
promoting inter about interoperability
policy that's coming up or has said
already time is why so the second was
diversity or the data types so I looked
at these specific for data types based
on the prior literature that kind of
evaluated what kind of information was
most useful for a primary care provider
following a hospital discharge so the
first was someone who karakurt's the
second was a radiology results that lab
results and medical history and I
basically counted the number of these
data types at a hospital said that they
were able to transmit routinely to try
to follow up providers after a patient
hospitalization and so this came from
the AAA annual survey I'm sorry yep
a annual surveys IT supplement the third
was breath for partner types and that is
again looking at the HIIT supplement
asking hospitals to what type of
provider can you send information to so
ambulatory care providers outside the
hospital system long-term care
post-acute care providers and behavioral
health providers and then I looked at
the approach and with the idea that
while there as you probably know there
are two main approaches to sending
information but push otherwise known as
direct or pull which is using a kind of
uploading all the data into a third
party database allowing providers to
kind of download that whenever they need
it so because of how pretty much
everyone has the capability of what
using push I looked at whether a
hospital was able to use one method or
both and really that came down to
whether they could use just push or if
they had the ability to use push and
pull so both are useful for care
coordination but there are studies that
show that pull having having the ability
to do actually both
it makes is associated with a higher
probability of that physician actually
accessing the information and again this
came from the OHA I know mighty
supplement survey so this was a
retrospective observational study using
data from 2014 to 2015 in a used
regression analysis with mix effects
with cluster centered airs at the
hospital level and it controls for a
variety of other factors that might
influence health information exchange
such as the year the size of the
hospital where the hospital was located
whether it was part of a healthcare
system whether it was owned by a
for-profit or nonprofit or government
hospital and then some measures of
patient characteristics such as the case
mixer dish and all these things that are
maybe interesting to you maybe not so
this was basically how I got my data so
the aah a survey gave me information on
hospital demographics and then I
connected that to information on whether
the hospital participated in an
alternative payment model from a variety
sources including the Leavitt Partners
ACO database and then data from Medicare
and the age a survey I added some
community control data from the area
health resource file and then and then
data on health information exchange from
the aah a survey and the meaningful use
program
so my final analytic data set had 800
hospitals in it from the volume analysis
1,700 hospitals in it for the diversity
and breadth analysis and 1,400 hospitals
in it from the depth analysis and the
reason why the DEF analysis I ended up
dropping about 300 hospitals there was
because 300 hospitals actually said that
they couldn't do either either push or
pull and so for them I just decided they
were other things that they had to worry
about health care mission exchange was
probably not one of them and and it was
a would be kind of weird to keep them in
this analysis they had other things
going on a lot of these turned out to be
royal rural
so there are some limitations I'm sure
many of you might be thinking about
already so the dimensions are measured
independently at the hospital level so I
don't really have a good way of telling
you know - for what kind of patients was
what kind of sent Davis sent and to whom
so it was really kind of aggregated at
the hospital level
I have no measure of who the data was
sent to so I just know that data was
sent I don't know if it was sent to
someone with it the system somebody
outside of the system a competing
Hospital it doesn't really tell me so
because I was only able to get data for
two years I do have limited causal
inference so I can't actually say if
alternative payment models lead to
greater information exchange or if
hospitals that participate an
alternative upon payment models already
have greater engagement in health
information exchange and finally I have
limited generalizability so as I
mentioned I ended up dropping a lot of
small rural hospitals and and then at
the same time the the volume analysis
was limited to hospitals that attested
to stage two so here are my findings so
this is a kind of descriptive table of
all the hospitals in the analysis and
it's a lot of data and basically the
idea is that the hospitals in my sample
tended to have really high participation
in alternative models begin with there
are more likely to be large urban
teaching hospitals part of healthcare
systems and nonprofit hospitals so here
are my effects so these are average
marginal effects basically suggesting
that for hospitals that participated in
an alternative payment model they tend
to send information for 11 percentage
points fewer patients they say send
point to eight more data types point two
seven to two point two seven more
partner types and then the likelihood of
the sending data with both push and pull
methods versus just push or pull is
about one point six times greater for
hospitals that they'll participate in
alternate
models so to put these numbers in
context what I did was project out so
this is looking at for some for a
average nonprofit hospital holding all
Hospital characteristics at their
average if a hospital participated in
the alternative payment model they would
on average be expected to send data for
about 51 percent of their discharge
patients versus 62 percent for hospitals
that did not participate in alternative
payment models they would be expected to
have three data types versus hospitals
versus 2.8 data types for hospitals that
did not participate in alternative
payment models and then for breath they
would be expected to send data to 1.7
partner types versus just 1.4 for
hospitals that did not participate and
then for deaths the probability of a
hospital that participated in
alternative payment models of sending
data we have both push and pull methods
was 80 percent versus 72 percent for
hospitals that did not participate in
alternative payment models again this is
just predicted for like an average
nonprofit hospital so I guess initially
when I found these results I thought I
might have made a mistake like I was
hoping to see kind of a higher bits
across all four but what we did find was
that volume was lower for hospitals that
participated in alternative payment
models versus not and what we thought
might be happening here is that
hospitals that do participate in
alternate payment models are really
focusing on it and improving the
infrastructure and hie capabilities with
their affiliated partners so especially
something like an ACO where you have
specific partners that you are working
with you might hospitals might be really
investing in the structures a technical
structures and the information workflows
to kind of get that information to those
specific partners and that might lead to
a lower hie volume but greater hie death
breath and
diversity hahaha that we were finding
the second possibility is that these
hospitals are really focusing on
specific use cases so focusing in on
patients that are very complex or have
chronic diseases for sending information
versus just sending information for all
of their patients and finally one plot
might be that hospitals that are
participating these programs are really
investing in a lot of different quality
improvement efforts and that might lead
to more physician burnout or things like
that where it's just harder for
providers to really get to send
information or or include those work
fluids in their routines because they've
got other things going on and I'd be
interested in hearing your thoughts on
that as well so implications and future
direction so one is that I guess and the
major takeaway from this is that
incentive programs like alternative
payment models are facilitating greater
engagement in health information
exchange however there might still be
barriers to getting that information
exchange and I think we are still very
far away from that world of
interconnectivity than a lot of us hope
that we'll have one day so ways to
improve information exchange or cross
into across organizational boundaries
might be to promote patient access to
data so there's some third-party patient
facing applications that allow you to
download your information and send it to
specific providers as you want and that
might be becoming more popular
especially as we move toward an open
standard interface for information
exchange second might be to the
standardized hie sending processes so
that means really looking at workflows
and technology and how we can make it
easier for providers actually access and
use and send information the third I
mentioned earlier is the 10% threshold
under the EHR Incentive program has not
really gone out and I think that's
that's quite low I'd like to see it a
little bit higher and I think hospitals
can make it and then fourth and this is
kind of an area that I think would be
really interest
to explore with you guys would be to
identify high-value HIV use cases so it
really could be that it's not very
useful to just send information now for
every single one your patients that are
discharged from the hospital so let's
look at specific use cases are there
certain key patient populations that
experience more fragmented care for
which we really need to focus on getting
information out so there are a lot of
next steps that someone could take
looking at this study and I'd like to do
some of them there's a lot here so the
first would be like I said identify high
and low value use cases for elephant
nation health information exchange in
one way that this can be done is looking
at you know the patient populations and
if we have some kind of measure of who
looked at data we could really see
whether looking at data and sending
information and leads the better patient
outcomes another kind of direction I
want to take this is looking at network
effects so you know what this this study
kind of looks at is who's in your shared
payment network and and then looking at
who's in your shared information network
and seeing if those overlap and whether
over lab leads the better patient care
and then one interesting kind of
question is if look at the kind of the
digital divide
so for who is information being sent and
do they tend to be those with better
access to care better insurance coverage
and if so there are really important
implications here for patients who might
have lower access to care and lower
quality care I think something really
interesting that's happening here in
Oregon is this idea of incorporating
social determinants of health data into
the EHR and I'd like to kind of explore
what this means for patient care and
care coordination so a lot of low-income
patients homeless patients patients who
don't have a lot of access have really
fragmented care and theory these are the
folks who really need take who could
really benefit from technology like
health information exchange so looking
at what's happening specifically with
this patient
relation would be of interest to me
and similarly CCO 2.0 is trying to link
data behavioral health with mental but
sorry medical medical data and so what
are the implications of that and what
can we do with that data and do patients
even want their medical providers
knowing about their behavioral health
and social service access and then
something kind of picked up at Carnegie
Mellon and I would love to kind of
explore would be how we can use text
analytics the kind of support this kind
of works so one kind of related maybe
ideas just looking at my free text in
the EHR there's a lot of that that that
isn't being used and understanding how
information containing those chemical
notes can improve patient care so yeah
that is this study and their nutshell
and I'd be interested in hearing your
thoughts and discussing more and if
anyone wants to chat I'm around thank
you
Thanks I really enjoyed that one
question I had based off of some of your
later comment was you talked about maybe
we should look at maybe meaningful use
of hie versus just any use and I'm
wondering your first thoughts on what
would be a good measure of meaningful
use of hie if you had to take a first
hack at that yeah that's a really me
comes understanding they use cases so I
think the meaningful use of hie and
that's kind of what I was trying to get
at it isn't just about sending data like
the meaningful use program is trying to
capture it's about who are you sending
data to and for what patients and how is
that data being used and what data is it
so a lot of people have criticized the
summary of care record document because
it's it seems kind of innocuous it's not
very useful to a lot of physicians and
so that's a good question and I have yet
to answer it I think it really depends
on the patient and the provider yeah
right so you know trying to
yeah actually make it easier to do yeah
I think that's a very those are two
really great points I think kind of
speaking to your first point about Hsu
being an integrated system what so part
of part of my thought process behind
this is looking at like not just looking
at integrated systems as still different
kind of provider groups but all within
the same system that share information
and if you can look at maybe the
metadata behind access to information
it's almost the interesting kind of
experiment in a way looking at an
integrated health system who have shared
information and seeing whether that
results in better outcomes and say
another system I mean there's there's a
lot there's a lot of confounding factors
in there but like where this really
applies might be yeah
Pittsburgh was a great example where
where I got my master's degree we had
two really powerful healthcare systems
and they refused to talk to each other
and looking at something like that where
you have patients who are going to both
systems and information is not
necessarily being transferred and
comparing kind of how information
exchange might actually impact patient
outcomes the thing that goes back to the
question you asked was might for some
patience and it might not for the
majority of patients and we don't know
and then your question about the 21st
century cures hack it's it's interesting
what's happening I think there's a lot
of talk about moving to I think you're
referring to the open api's yeah and
that would that would be interesting
provided that there are policies in
place that allow and really encourage
more third-party kind of innovation in
that space so I think where we might see
that kind of world of internet
interconnectivity
really happen would be if we can get a
lot of companies but tech companies that
can facilitate those bridges and then
even though you know the policies are in
place there's a lot of kind of we still
have a long way to go in with that
technology so there was I get the name
of this person
Amy Oh last year and kind of did a just
to show what you know what opening eyes
could look like took in theory you're
the same you know they have the same
standards and took two EHRs and kind of
map them onto each other and just showed
how much was missing or how much error
there was and this was just in like
medication information so I think we
still have a long way to go to really
achieving my kind of open environment
but the policy framework I think is
moving that direction yeah epic is not I
think is epic is a kind of almost I'm
gonna stop talking about that thing
unless anyone wants to know my thoughts
on epic uh-huh but yeah so I'm steeped a
second I'm kind of operationally
responsible for a lot of the hie I know
Hsu a week we can talk about some of
things afterwards there's kind of two
one observation then just kind of a
question I feel like a lot of the idea
of the benefit of hie is predicated on
the fact that it's gonna reduce waste in
healthcare and overuse my sense though I
have you know when when I look at the
waste literature and there is kind of an
overuse literature out there I I don't
you know there's a number of different
what I'll just
all hypotheses at this point but what's
driving that and and I wonder if that we
sort of overestimate the effect of
missing information sometimes on what's
driving waste in health care and that it
isn't all the waste isn't in my you know
my sense is maybe all the waste is you
know it's much more structural alignment
incentive problems than it is just
missing information but do you do you
have a good sense of how well we've
constrained kind of you know information
needs as driving waste in health care
that's a really good question
I think answering that question I'm
finding like a large part of my research
kind of focuses on technology but then
in order to answer those kind of
questions you end up having a look at
the other parts of a health care system
in terms of looking at the actual like
information aspect of fragmentation and
how that contributes the overall picture
I don't know any anyone who's done that
kind of scoping work and that would be
an interesting area to look at I do know
that you're right a lot of the kind of
use cases that kind of predict
information exchange being helpful to
cost is looks at like redundancy or
really emergency department visits
there's kind of a really big one and
something I learned recently and I was
like that's amazing yeah this idea of
care coordination might actually not
necessarily saving health systems money
so a lot of the the literature on care
coordination in general not just
information exchange finds that yes care
quality is improving a little bit but
when you actually look at the cost
benefit analysis it actually cost more
money to provide more I you know
coordinated care and I guess when you
really think of it that way and the
sense of a large picture it doesn't make
sense so it's a really valid questions
yeah yeah the other thing thanks for
thanks for that response the other one I
was interested in is you know my kind of
view of this is that there is very
little in terms of a framework for
implementation
right and so each individual
organization is basically the vendor
kind of gives them some tools sort of
and it's basically a go you know turn it
on yeah basically but in terms of how
you publish your provider directory how
often you updated what you tell other
organizations to send to how you
distribute those messages what those
messages are packaged in how they get
sent that's all in the wild yeah so it's
like you know this stuff people are just
pumping it out everything was about
sending right yeah there's no read
receipt built in to direct and we really
don't have a good sense of how that
process and so you know all the trust
and agreement is kind of just no one's
really defined how that process needs to
work my sense is you know we're just
gonna continue pumping out useless
information until someone sort of does
that hard work yeah yeah that's a really
big criticism wheels so there was a lot
of familiar a lot of federal investment
in these third-party organizations that
were supposed to create those governing
frameworks but there was no standard way
there was no blueprint there was no
guideline we just said go for it take
our money and come up with things and
that's and even we even within the folks
who are doing it with in a single vendor
that same problem is exists actually
either one of you a question
what about teff kheh well teff qey solve
these problems the trusted exchange
framework I don't know that it's clear
yet that it will I'm not sure it's
defined enough at this stage yeah it's
there's a lot of different forces policy
levels competition vendors this is a big
big issue not just you know provider
competition
yes it's a good question
we we need we need total fluidity of the
data at the you know the the I mean
years ago I can't remember who it was it
may have been Farzad mostashari I said
you know EHR vendors should compete on
sort of features and interfaces and the
data should be standardized or the
famous Stan Huff quote that I once said
and it got tweeted so now it's often
attributed it to me but it's not me
there should be socialism for the data
and capitalism for the EHR you know so
the the you know the data should be
sacrosanct you know and and easily move
back and forth but as you both mentioned
there's obvious challenges to doing that
what Steve was saying there's waste in
just the reordering of a lab that's
already been done but there's also
system waste as far as the salaries of
all those people who have to go scrub
the charts or call the family again to
ask why this hasn't been done or any
number of things has there been any and
that might be caught before it results
in additional hospital admissions or EDD
visits because the care is eventually
getting coordinated yeah is there any
any work on the cost of the
administrative burden of even
successfully getting data from other
places yeah and that's a really great
point and there has been work on that
it's a few years old so I'm having
trouble kind of recalling what they
found but yes I recall working with
someone on a project at U of M and
before he does any surgery he has this
secretary called the the patient's
providers and gathered all the faxes and
literally piles of these papers that she
then types into the EHR
this is that no I really fancy hospital
with really fancy technology and yeah
it's kind of that kind of redundancy
that works that manpower that I think
you don't often think about as a benefit
of this kind of technology so yes there
is work on it and I can find that paper
and send it to you yeah right that's
that's what I my opinion hie is done I
think they're really high-value use
cases are those operational things that
have some touch on care like we're in
tirana ly doing
hie referrals right there's a very green
ROI on that we have hundreds of people
processing paper and referrals and if we
can package those electronically and so
I think those are the things the other
one you know that sort of sits outside
you know the PDMP integration even
though it's kind of owned all by one
vendor in the United States like that's
a very high-value use case and then the
so prescription drug monitoring programs
right yeah and then the other one is you
state registries for immunizations yeah
right but I think my for my vantage
point the hie that I see is valuable
that the organization can figure out how
to organize around and get trusted
agreement are those you know those
low-hanging fruit business cases whether
these very paper heavy processes but the
nebulous we're just gonna let all the
information out there and somehow it's
gonna improve care is kind of it's it's
pretty pie in the sky yeah and I think
we're seeing a lot of the effects so
many organizations are actually taking
those meaningful use to summaries of
care and just black holding them down
route them into anybody yeah exactly I
mean that was the big criticism behind
requiring yeah
this is really interesting
where did direct messaging go I mean
this you know because we use email all
the time and we send documents back and
forth and the idea was that this would
be a secure HIPAA compliant email
provider to provider right and and you
could easily regulate the the format of
a domain so that you could send it
across and and the content would would
just be whatever media you you attached
to it and that that's one question the
other question is has hl7 sort of sort
of purposely not jumped into this type
of question they just said we provide
the language but not the policy or have
there been organizations you know
nonprofits or whatever with similar
missions to hl7 who've tried to say hey
look this is how we should do it
and that's something I've been
interested in hearing you guys I haven't
studied it direct as much but I've read
is just it's happening there he the
question of hl7 is a good one and I do
believe it's it's been adopted in the
newest kind of certification so I guess
your question about whether there's an
organization out there that's really
pushing for something
yeah so that kind of got referring to
those comment woman where like not just
about how data is captured in story but
actually the the governing processes
that go above it yeah not I believe
there was an attempt to put something
together by ONC last I read like those
last year they actually had started
putting together like a governing
framework but they wanted to push out I
think they're just
yeah regulatory acronyms I think direct
still exists yeah yeah
but but I think that you know I mean so
I mean all direct really is a secure
email with this kind of layer on top of
it but you you know I I don't know you
know I hear about people emailing stuff
you know from provider to provider all
the time I mean actually you probably
know more about this and I would but you
know and then somehow it gets put into
epic you know someone sends a picture of
something I mean that's kind of what
direct was for it's just a direct
point-to-point but I don't know how much
how much a non direct direct
communication there is versus the use of
direct
oesn't if that gave you a bit of the
answer you got so from the hospital
there's a hospital's participation in
ACO mm-hmm
facilitate their use of hie I do wonder
if you looked at it from the other end
and said and affiliated partners
involvement in an ACO does that change
their uptake of that because I know from
a perspective of mind being outside of
hospital system if you're in an ACO
you're going to use those systems more
because it's part of the system now why
you couldn't answer that but the
perspective you don't have all those
competing priorities that Steve and Bill
talked about that look at epic itself
and looking at trying to prevent leak
you spend a lot of time in trying to
prevent leakage out of your system that
has a capital return for you or I sorry
a financial return for you but why would
I make it really easy to send outside of
my organization other than it's good for
the patient yeah so yeah I think that
was actually my my my if I had a you
know a goal in mind for my dissertation
when I was coming up with it was
actually to look at a provider side of
or primary care providers specifically
well and their uptake of hie because I
think it's a lot harder and what's
happening with provider consolidate and
all those other stuff kind of speaks to
some of those challenges but it was hard
to get data on that and there's some
there's some surveys out there that can
be used but if it was a really great
question and there's yeah so want one
other didn't put it up there but my I
did look at network effects so looking
at what providers were in the same ACO
and whether that kind of facilitated
some kind of patient sharing kind of
changes and patient sharing patterns but
I really wanted to look at was whether
that's the information exchange and it
was it's it's hard to get data on
information exchange from the provider
level but that would be direction I
would hope to go in
and there is kind of a study that were
working on now that looks at kind of
that keeping patient care within the
network and whether that hasn't impact
on how comes and especially so we looked
at MSS PA cos in the country and we're
finding that a cos they were able to
keep more of their patient care within
their network actually we're managing to
lower their costs more so than patients
they do a cos that had no patients going
everywhere else so there is something
there and I think it may seem might be a
big part of it there is yeah yeah that's
a really great question thank you
I'm sure we'll all be talking more with
you now that you're in the neighborhood
yeah thank you thank you